you
hi everyone and welcome to cloud on air
live webinars from Google cloud that we
host every Tuesday just to remind you
can ask questions on the platform at any
point we have Google is standing by to
answer them so let's get started hi I'm
Alicia Patterson I'm a program delivery
consultant with Apogee which is part of
Google cloud and I get to work with big
brands across the planet and help them
leverage AP is to deliver impact in
their businesses our webcast today is
being co-presented with Walgreens I'm
July to be joined today by Aaron news
Chong who's the director for core
digital products and innovation at
Walgreens great to have you with us
thanks Alicia so today we're going to
spend a little bit of time talking about
what it means to build API products and
then Aaron's going to talk about how
Walgreens has been able to use API is to
extend their assets into developer
ecosystems and then that will be
followed by a responding to your
questions so let's jump into it so what
do we mean when we talk about API is as
products and how can productizing api's
provide opportunities for business this
can be a difficult concept for product
people to get their head around as at
best api is i've seen as points of
technical integration and is it worse IT
jargon I have a simple of example a
simple example from the insurance
business that I find product
professionals can often relate to and it
helps illustrate the ability for api's
to extend into new channels of
opportunity while also extending a
better customer experience so no one
really enjoys shopping forensics
insurance it's one of those kind of
necessary things that we have in our
lives and sure as companies have a tough
time creating a great customer
experience because the times you
typically engage with an insurance
company is when you have to pay them a
bunch of money to buy insurance or when
you're a key claim because something
that you hoped wouldn't happen just
happened so I think about this recent
because I brought a drone like an
unmanned aerial vehicle and I was
concerned that it might fall out of the
sky from time to time and land on
something expensive so its shopping for
insurance and I found this product
offered by a large multinational insurer
company and they made the product
available through their traditional high
commission agent network as well as
directly online there's like $800 for a
million dollars of coverage that lasted
a year I thought it was a bit pricey for
me probably a bit pricey true for more
than a half a million people that bought
consumer drones in the US last year and
then I found a mobile app more of a
niche insurance offering when you launch
this app it draws a map drops a pin
where you are and says if you want to
fly your drone for the next hour any
site anywhere in that radius then it
costs like 20 dollars or something for a
million dollars of coverage which is a
much better offering for a casual flyer
and that made me think the insurance
companies core business is assessing an
underwriting risk and putting a price on
that and obviously having a margin where
they make their business had they been
API first and productized to the API it
would have allowed them to extend their
core business to powered this app the
one that I found and indeed many others
like it and what's more they had api's
to quote and sell their drone insurance
they could give it to drone
manufacturers who think they could build
it directly into their product
experience when you use the app or
whatever at all reused to control your
drone one of the options might include
purchasing insurance for that flight and
surely there's no better experience and
not having to worry about going and
getting insurance before you can go
flying with your drone and said you can
just fly your drone with the peace of
mind that you can purchase insurance for
that particular flight if you need to
and then it also occurred to me that the
insurance company today uses obviously a
lot of data to inform its risk
assessment and pricing however typically
the only data it's able to collect when
running its business is when someone
buys a policy or when they make a claim
whereas if they were to productize to
the API and serve applications like the
one that I found then they could also
have visibility of how often people fly
they drive their drones and where they
fly the drones and for how long data
that could significantly enrich their
ability to assess that insurance risk
productizing the API
creating an API to quote install drone
insurance and then offering it to an
external ecosystem of app developers and
drone
would not only extend their product to a
much greater reach but also give them
richer data with which to make their
underwriting assessment not to mention
they could also use those API Zen to
power their traditional agent Network
and their website so what does
productizing an api mean there are many
aspects that we might talk about but for
this webcast we're just going to focus
on these three items so outside-in means
delivering a sari developing a strong
focus on the external business or user
name and making sure your organization
connects that perspective directly to
development work we'll talk more on that
in a moment
speed to market recognizes the cost of
software and supporting infrastructure
is lower now than it ever has been
before
thanks growth in cloud driving down
infrastructure costs software frameworks
with built in foundations at speed
development and open source platforms
allow for maximum collaboration because
of this the manner in which software is
built needs to change to modern agile
practices with a strong focus on
removing obstacles to fast delivery the
digital products are never really
finished right because there's always
some new technology or new device that
your customers expect to engage you
across iterative iterative delivery ask
that you take an iterative product
delivery approach to your AP is that you
have a product backlog you make regular
ongoing improvements to them over time
the same as you would for your website
or your mobile apps or indeed any other
product that you might own so each of
these we can break down into further
supporting ideas a couple of which I'll
talk about now but also much is covered
in our complete guide to API products
ebook which is the length which will
provide a little bit later on this
webcast so let's look more closely at
outside in outside in is a mindset right
it's a design philosophy supported by
organizational constructs such as team
and role definitions and software
development methodologies it moves the
problem domain from an IT question of
exposing data
or other assets instead of the question
of how that data will be used from a
consumption perspective
traditionally IT teams think about api's
from an exposure point of view we can
just expose a service and be finished
this brings with a risk of surfacing
complexity since the people who build
solutions on your back-end systems are
close to their systems and grouted in
their idiosyncrasies if your API
development team consists of just your
back-end developers then you run the
risk of exposing your complexity with
your data whether it be complicated
call-outs to disparate services or an
assumed understanding of the underlying
data architecture exposing complexity
creates friction for the developers who
are consume your ap is slowing down
their adoption and their ability to
build solutions on top of your assets
however thinking about it from the end
users point of view leads to better
results for the business averages most
successful customers start from the user
thinking about what the users experience
will be like
and working backwards from there
providing the application developer with
great api's reduces the complexity they
face in creating new applications the
application developer is free to focus
on user experience and iterate on a few
different designs the API team makes is
possible by providing easy-to-use api's
with consistent interfaces and security
patterns the API team builds an API
facade on the existing services based on
understanding of the application
developers needs and abstracting away
the complexities one way to ensure that
you bring an outside-in perspective to
development is to make sure you have
that your development team includes a
product owner ideally a product manager
for the API or the relevant product
owner for that business area someone who
is close to the needs of the users and
the app developers that are creating
software for them so packaging up an API
as a product means considering the
outside-in design and making it easy for
those consuming developers to find and
use your API to solve the software
problems that they face helping them
with things like great documentation
that makes it clear what the API does
and how it might be used like with
e-commerce your goal is to make the
experience as frictionless as possible
remove barriers to discovery and
adoption by your app developers in the
same way an online retailer seeks to
remove unnecessary clicks between a
customer's purchase decision and their
checkout in the API product world you
should be looking to minimize the time
it takes for your app developers to get
to their first
hello wall right there first use of your
API s so what does an API product
experience look like I have a conceptual
model that's that presents a a metaphor
if you like for the API product
experience from an app developers
perspective so for this metaphor I want
you to imagine that your eight-year-old
niece it's a birthday and she's asked
you for a Lego castle so you go down to
the Lego store when you walk in you see
rows of Lego boxes on shelves like the
whole catalogue is on display making it
really easy for you to quickly find the
box that has a picture of a castle on it
that looks like the kind of thing you
think she might enjoy when you look at
the box you see that it says ages 6 to
65 like it describes the target audience
right for that for the product it has
pictures on the box of what the
completed set will look like in fact
there are pictures of other things you
can use the contents to build there like
other use cases for the the contents of
the box you're pretty sure it's what you
want but you're even more sure when you
see a glass case on display nearby where
one has been assembled already you can
look at that one it's like a reference
implementation for the product so
confident it's exactly what you love you
can buy it you're out of the store
within 5 minutes knowing that you've
solved the problem that you have now
imagine that experience built by someone
close to the back end that might taken
an exposure approach like an inside-out
approach in that case when you go down
to the Lego store but you can't walk
straight in of course because you need
to first have an NDA and contract sign
to let you come in
the store and there but you can come
into the store Ryland Singh you know
Rose our products on shelves
you see buckets and buckets of all
different types of Lego in all different
types of color all the complexity is on
display here and now it's your job to
figure out how you're going to assemble
all those pieces together to make a
castle you've got no choice but to go
honest I want to help and they say ya
get a thousand of the gray bricks and a
thousand the brown bricks whatever else
and you're in there for ages when you
walk out you have this big bag of all
this Lego and you're still not even sure
how it's going to come together to
create the thing that you need to give
to your niece in spite of spending ages
and ages in the store so the outside in
perspective what a scene that a store
full of buckets of bricks is too complex
of folks looking to buy a gift for their
child as with AP is to create a great
product it is important to bring the
outside perspective outside in
perspective to the development team so
one organization that's been able to do
this with great result is Walgreens and
Aaron is here today to tell us a little
bit about that journey thanks Alicia
so as you're probably aware Walgreens is
a very large and very diverse
organization and within the company we
have a lot of different businesses
operating independently within the
overall corporation so my team the core
digital products team our mission is to
create and scale and operate the
products and features that aren't
aligned to any one specific business but
those that sort of support and add value
across all of our businesses and one
very important component of my team is
our third party API program which is
what I'm excited to talk to you about
today so I've been in my current role
for just a few months now and I but I've
been with Walgreens for almost seven
years now so I was there back in 2012
when we launched our very first API
and I remember it what seemed very novel
at the time so I was reading a tech blog
and there was a headline that said the
apocalypse is upon us Walgreens has an
API so it might not have always seemed
obvious from the outside but really from
inside the organization the conditions
were really right for us to embark on
this journey and there I think three key
things that really set us up for success
to do that so the first thing is that we
had a really strong foundational digital
strategy and mobile strategy that we're
building off of toward an API program
secondly we had the right mindset within
the organization to sort of embrace
disruption and think about new and
better ways of doing things and third we
were in a stage of maturity within
ecommerce where we were really
developing and building out the product
management discipline fundamentally so
the timing was really great right and
let me just walk in a little bit more
detail through kind of each of those
with you here so the first is our API
program strategy so at the time we had
some very very innovative first to
market type digital solutions that we
had come up with like the ability to
scan your pill bottle and automatically
refill your prescription that way and
the ability to didn't scuse me print
photos directly from your camera roll
directly into the Walgreens store and we
came up with these ideas and
opportunities really by just reimagining
those sort of core central value
proposition elements that we had in our
retail locations and thought about how
they would manifest as a great digital
experience right and then beyond
building out those capabilities just due
to the nature of the features that we
had built we really had to connect them
from the very beginning into our
physical location so we had a really
rich and robust omni-channel experience
from very early on and this was
extremely powerful for us as you can
imagine and kind of beyond just
connecting our own digital experiences
our leadership in e-commerce at the time
realized that it could be even more
powerful if we could kind of unlock
those core capabilities to an even wider
audience by connecting to this broader
developer ecosystem so the second piece
that I think was really critical for us
was having a business that was sort of
the right opportunity to pursue this
type of innovation and so we did have a
business photo at the time was going
through massive transformation if you're
thinking back to then and very quickly
gone
from a state where people were
developing rolls of film from cameras to
doing digital photography and very
quickly then even right through that
into taking all of your photos from
straight from your smartphone right and
you know coupled with the smartphone
photography was this development of you
know hundreds if not thousands of
different sort of photo taking and
editing and collage apps that were
happening and then you know the output
of that being so easy to just with one
click share to social media so that was
your entire experience from capture
through editing to sharing and it's sort
of had elbowed out this need to print a
physical product which had which had
been the focal point of taking photos
not and then not to you know distant
past and so you know we were kind of
looking for for ways to kind of solve
that riddle and you know I get a ton of
credit to the head of our photo business
at that time is that he really
understood and appreciated that this
change wasn't necessarily a problem for
us it was actually a really big
opportunity and he embraced that and you
know it was really really excited to see
what a program like this could do and
and honestly right now I think that
almost every industry is being disrupted
in this kind of way so hard to even
think of a business that this kind of
solution couldn't be appropriate for so
the the third piece for us again was the
fact that we were really building out
this product management discipline and
way of thinking within the organization
and you know we kind of looked at
everything as how do we manage this
thing in a product way and you know I've
I've been in product for a very very
long time and I'm custom to identifying
opportunities as the things that form
the intersection of the features that
would specifically drive value for the
business and the things that the you
know the customer value is coming from
and what I think is really interesting
about managing api's as products is that
it layers on this third dimension which
is the things that drive value for the
developer and and in fact it's really
different because the value you know
we're used to driving value for the
customer but there
value that you drive for the customer is
actually indirect and so you spend your
time just thinking about what the
possibilities could be for that
opportunity and then making the best
possible product that meets the needs of
the developer to unlock that and kind of
manage that customer experience that's
great
so that's the outside end that you were
talking about earlier yeah so the
example that you see here you know we
thought about what our problem statement
was which is how do we reengage these
smartphone users with photo printing and
we looked at our business value
component which is we really we need to
increase revenue from photo services we
need to get people printing again and
what we thought the customers wanted
which was you know a fun and simple way
to keep doing those things that they
were really enjoying but to potentially
layer on a very easy way to have sort of
a physical component of output from what
they had created that that that captures
not just you know what they took the
photo of in the first place but the
experience of actually creating and
having this sort of social environment
in which they were using their photos
and so then we really thought about that
the fact that we needed that partnership
with the developers because that's where
the customers were and you know we
realized that this could work because we
had a lot of value that we could offer
to the developer community and so we
embarked on our very first API and as it
turned out this this formula that we had
which was the right strategy the right
mindset and the product management
approach really worked for us
and because we had created this great
product with the outcome in mind it was
easy to use it had a great feature set
there is an opportunity for earning
revenue from the developers which was
actually pretty rare back then and the
marketing opportunities that came from a
partnership with the Walgreens brand we
had you know tons of interest in the
program and in fact just in terms of
scale we actually have had over 200
integrations just for our photo printing
eye API since we launched it that's a
great result and we've seen a ton of
benefit
from from this the API in the program in
general specifically here there was a
significant amount of direct revenue
that started coming from this channel
and still to this day is actually
driving you know measurable impact and
influencing bringing photo back to being
a growth business for us again and
secondly you know we have found that the
developer community is very good at
identifying new ways and opportunities
to attract customers back into wanting
to to print which is great and in there
they're doing this because we're giving
them these great tools and the
flexibility to problem-solve on their
own without having the ideas have to
come from us and then you know finally I
think that this kind of partnership has
really helped the industry as a whole to
become more innovative and some of the
innovation that's come out of that we've
actually been able to kind of repurpose
and bring into our our own digital
assets as well so one more common in
this honestly you know I'm telling the
story now is the perspective of being
leader of the team that includes the API
program but back then I was not that I
wasn't a mobile product person I wasn't
an API product person I was the photo
product person right and so it's really
difficult for me to kind of give up that
control of my customer that I had
guarded so carefully to you know
completely external parties who were
actually defining parts of the customer
journey but at the same time it was
actually really liberating because you
know there were things that I couldn't
do that maybe I would have wanted to do
and I couldn't because of brand
constraints or because of resource
constraints or because of technology
constraints and a lot of these partners
that we had didn't have the same
constraints and it was really excited to
kind of see what they could do with that
freedom and and really at the end of the
day regardless of where the customer
journey started at the end of it they
were walking into a Walgreens store and
so they were getting a really important
part of our customer journey that was
owned by us oh that's wonderful
so over the past five plus years we've
continued to build out our portfolio of
API products and we've continued to kind
of identify opportunities to extend
those core central capabilities of
Walgreens particularly in areas of
transition or disruption and in a way
that's enticing to the developer
community so today we have this whole
portfolio of API products that we manage
for photo we didn't stop with prints so
almost immediately after we launched the
printing API our developer partners
started approaching us with ideas for
other types of products that they like
to be able to create like greeting cards
posters canvases photo books and you
know this was this was really great
because you know our organizational
expertise within Walgreens wouldn't was
not necessarily creating mobile product
photo product builders and you know we
were really excited because we had these
products that we could create we
couldn't always get to them but we could
actually let our partners be the ones to
focus on things like building the best
mobile photo collage creator and they
were able to actually launch those
products before we could launch it in
our in our own mobile app so after photo
we moved on into the pharmacy space
obviously this is kind of big in central
to our business so we initially went out
with a prescription refill and transfer
API so and obviously anything that has
to do with pharmacy and Walgreens the
scale and the reach is so great that
it's a very appealing partnership for
any of our potential partners and
specifically our large healthcare
provider partners are motivated to try
to drive patients to take their
medications in a timely fashion for
example so any way they can sort of
reduce friction in the process of you
know getting the recommended
prescription into a Walgreens store to
be filled without any of those drop-off
points that it would require from
actually you know physically making
someone go to a separate experience and
so you know this is a huge interest in
that program beyond that other aspects
of healthcare as well beyond just
prescribe
Asians we went through a period where we
sort of kicked off a tremendous health
care Innovation Program which has
continued on to this day one aspect of
that was really partnering potentially
with fitness device tracking companies
and so looking for ways to kind of
engage in healthcare and wellness
outside of just the medications this is
a great opportunity so we actually
launched we call our balance rewards for
healthy choices API which means that
customer can actually you know sync up
and integrate their fitness device with
this API and automatically be rewarded
with our loyalty program points which
they can then apply toward rewards
within the company that's pretty cool
which is really exciting so moving
beyond that most recently we've been
spending a lot of time working on
shopping and couponing experiences and
so just kind of going back to the
mindset component you know retail
shopping Deal Seeking is is shifting a
lot right now in terms of the way
customers approach it and they're
definitely in most cases not coming
straight to Walgreens com2 do all of
that research and so we need to find new
ways to kind of get our experiences out
there where customers are searching and
shopping and deal seeking to kind of
bring them back into our network and so
a couple of things that we have number
one is there's a digital Offers API
which enables us to showcase
personalized offers for customers which
they can then clip to their loyalty
account and have that coupon
automatically be applied at checkout we
also have an Add to Cart API so we're
able to actually transfer a product
directly from you know any product
experience into a Walgreens comm cart
for fulfillment by our business so
thinking a lot more there we do have a
few more really exciting things coming
so definitely stay tuned stay tuned and
you know I just wanted to add as we kind
of take a look at this whole portfolio
of api's that we have here is that you
know
we weren't just coming to the table and
saying hey let's build an API
out-of-the-blue right we were actually
doing this in a way to respond to the
things that the company was focusing on
and thinking about and again especially
as these spaces were going through a lot
of transformation but I think that
actually planning out how to productize
a service as an external API has helped
us really get very good at building our
API to be really flexible and scalable
not just for external but for internal
use as well and what's really great is
that our API team both on the product
and engineering side has gotten really
really good at kind of encouraging our
developer community within Walgreens to
you know think about this approach and
and make things very developer friendly
from the beginning even if we aren't
originally intending it to surface it
outside of the organization so just as
an example we had a vendor who's
responsible for replenishing water
coolers in our store locations and they
wanted to use our store locating service
that we had that we were using
internally and using Apogee we were
actually able to open that up to them
very quickly and easily to accomplish
that goal and so just one final comment
that I want to make with respect to this
whole portfolio is that you know on top
of just sort of building the roadmap and
the features and building out these
capabilities we're constantly focusing
on how we can make it more
developer-friendly and how you know as
you mentioned before how important it is
to make that onboarding process as
smooth as possible because we we know we
have a lot of value here that we can
offer to develop our partners and we
just don't want there to be any
obstacles to them for getting on board
yeah so I just wanted to kind of talk a
little bit about what I think has helped
us be successful managing API is as
products and I know that every
organization is a little different the
resources the structure is a little bit
different but here's kind of some of the
things that I thought would be
applicable more broad
kind of what I think makes our API
product roadmap a success within
Walgreens
so the first piece is that we have a
product roadmap all right so we you know
again we manage it just like any other
product we have a backlog we have a
roadmap we integrate with the the
digital roadmap planning process that we
have across all of our digital product
teams and we participate in an event
that we do quarterly which is basically
a quarterly digital product roadmap
review and that includes not just the
digital product team but all of our
different core business stakeholders
across the different businesses IT
partners marketing partners and I think
that visibility into what we're doing
with our API program has driven really
great engagement secondly we have a
really great developer evangelist who is
actually a member of our product team so
he's an engineer and also a product
thinking person and I think that
partnership has been really really
critical for us to you know be able to
not only think about the API is in a
product way but also for him to be aware
of kind of what we're bringing out into
the market and beyond that we have
really really great tools that we use
that help us effectively kind of manage
the program so we can spend as much time
as possible thinking strategically and
less about the administrative part of
the job right so we have our developer
portal which is the entry point for the
developer community to come in to our
API program and to interface with us of
course we have Apogee which allows us to
kind of be a really good partner to our
developer community you know we have a
pretty small team and we have a lot of
partners we have over 300 partners right
now and so Apogee does a great job of
making that really seamless and
efficient for us to kind of managing you
know as across that large portfolio and
and furthermore for us to get really
easy access into sort of the data and
analytics around the program we also
have a really great central
communication tool that we use we use
camp so it helps anyone who is
interested in sort of following these
things you know from you know set up and
launch of these capabilities as it goes
through different types of tasks some
more technical or less technical than
others it's it's all in one place so it
makes it really seamless to Trek that's
through from beginning to end and then
finally from a tools perspective we
recently launched more of an
informational portal that's like less
technical than our developer portal and
this is something that we think is going
to be helpful both internally and for
our developer community to be able to
talk in more value centric language
about what this API program really is
and the benefits that it can drive it's
connecting more directly with actual
value absolutely and so last but
definitely not least we put a big focus
on you know as you do with any product
defining what success looks like for
that product and being able to report
out the performance against the key
metrics that we've defined from the
beginning and you know as interest in
the program has grown kind of beyond you
know digital product management we've
started actually putting together more
business centric dashboards and and
sometimes in partnership with our
marketing teams as well to really kind
of polish this and and to be able to
very clearly articulate the business
value and the success that these
programs have and that they can have so
hopefully that helps shed some light on
how we manage our API products within
Walgreens and I'm excited to answer a
few questions about the program so thank
you for having me and and and definitely
I would suggest also if I don't have
time to answer all the questions you can
always reach out to our team through our
developer portal at developer in
Stockholm Thank You Erin the kids it's
always great to hear your story because
it's great to hear an organization like
Walgreens create this platform and then
you know build an ecosystem of
participants you know that they're
actually adding value to your business
but also you know incentivizing them to
continue to contribute so it's such a
great story I love sharing it with
people so I did mention before we have
some resources I wanted to share with
you so we have
the complete guide to API products ebook
the link is available on the screen
there so I encourage you to go and look
there's a much sort of deeper dive there
and to know how to build and run API
programs as you know API products and
there's a microsite that's around that
as well that sort of dedicated to a
digital information there's some
customer stories and blogs there and of
course developer Walgreens calm to get
to walkins developer portal so now I'd
ask you to please stay tuned for the
live Q&A we're back to that in just less
than a minute
you
so thank you for saw the questions I see
rolling in so I'm showing some of those
on the screen and I'm gonna start ask
questions and Aaron will probably
respond for most of them so first
question
Aaron how do you manage the bureaucracy
within a large organization like
Walgreens when looking to build your API
products and expose additional service
yeah that that is definitely a big
factor for us and to me the key is
really always about relationships so I
think that's one thing that product
managers are trained to do really well
is to build relationships across
different parts of the organization and
to actually speak a lot of different
languages so to speak right and you know
it's really important to be able to
communicate not just what we're doing
but actually why we're doing it and
really lead with the value proposition
and what the benefit is to the
organization by you know doing and what
we're unlocking with this given service
or capability and you know beyond that I
think the team has really done a great
job of sort of building subject matter
expertise and credibility and we make
sure that we have those trained experts
present throughout the process you know
whether it's trying to get a security
approval or some other part of the
process and sort of building that trust
with all of our partners really kind of
helps us smooth the path forward through
some of that bureaucracy that can be in
place of course and I said that nothing
breeds success like success and you've
you've had such a successful story but
to your point earlier being able to tie
what you've done back to real
demonstrated value for the business that
gives you quite a platform internally
right to go and talk about your success
all right next question
where you're able to estimate or
quantify the assumed benefits of the
program of enabling out to external
developers prior to going down this path
yeah so you know it's it can be really
hard to do that because you know you
don't necessarily control all aspects of
the market you can't have a marketing
campaign that you plan out necessarily
right it's much more organic than that
and so what you really have to do is
focus kind of on the potential value and
you can kind of have after you define
what success will look like for this
this API
you can have sort of an addressable
market and you can have a target
customer which I actually might be a
target developer partner so you can kind
of put that framework loosely in place
but then you know once you've kind of
done that from a potential standpoint
you really just have to focus on
building the best product that's most
enticing and engaging for the developer
and putting that effort into it so that
you're really realizing that potential
value that you've established
Nepos and you can't you can't plan for
innovation and and to your point earlier
this there's probably far more
innovators outside the organization than
internally so you've you found some
people doing interesting things you
weren't anticipating you know but of
course you know being a we always had a
customers being able to try get very
very close to the end-user to the sort
of business center developers and then
be able to iterate quickly on how you
support them with API products I think
that ability iterate quickly you'll find
where the value is and they can start
building on top of that so the next
question I remembered the benefit of
experience if you can go back to the
start of the Walgreens API program is
there anything that you would do
differently yeah so honestly I mean I'd
say not a lot and I think you saw in my
story that we got really lucky that we
actually kind of had a lot of the right
pieces in place and I think we did a lot
of the right things from the beginning
and I you know I understand that not
everyone might have that that good
fortune to have all the right things in
place so I would just suggest for others
well I wouldn't necessarily change to
you know for another company to try to
replicate as many of those conditions
that I talked about as you can at least
to the extent that you can control it so
and that being said I do think that you
know if there was one thing I could do a
little bit differently was maybe
engaging a little bit earlier with our
digital marketing team about our
marketing strategy I think there's some
really unique things here about how you
market API programs that you know I
think we've been still working through
which is you know you really want the
the benefit the program you want the the
appetite and the engagement for the
program but the brand that's driving it
isn't your own brand and so the
considerations are a little bit
different again I think we're getting
there but I think if we had started
earlier remove
perfected that dance a little bit better
by no certainly sounds like you were
fortunate to have great vision for the
organization in terms of digital goals
but then also strong leadership right
both your executive level and your
director level that are able to execute
on the plans so Aaron how do you
communicate the value of api's to
business leadership and to product
stakeholders yeah so you know I've
definitely talked about this throughout
the presentation and a little bit
earlier but I think the most important
part of this is just speaking the right
language so you know if you're talking
to a marketing person you're talking
about things in terms of customer
acquisition and you bring to the table
an actual example with data that shows
how you've been able to bring customers
into becoming customers that have you
know through the API program come in and
driven broader value for the company and
if you're talking to a P&L owner or
merchant you're talking about things in
terms of EBIT and basket size right and
how you're driving value for them and
when you're talking to a someone on the
product team you're talking about things
like you know rapid test and learn and
outside an innovation and kind of how
these developer partners partnerships
have made our own products you know more
more effective and better neat meet the
needs of our customers okay great I
think we do touch on measurements but
I'll ask this question because I think
this is from a very practical level what
do you measure in your API program yeah
so we have some kind of standard things
that we typically measure you know like
the number of partners that we have for
a given API or the number of
transactions that are kind of standard
across all of them and then you know we
have some unique things for each that
are applicable to that API like the
number of rewards points that have been
awarded the number of coupons that have
been redeemed or the number of
prescriptions that have been refilled
which is great because I actually tying
the I guess the transactions on the API
level back to real business activities
and so I think the question is how do
you tie this back to business benefits
how do you measure developer
satisfaction yes so we have a couple
ways that we measure developer
satisfaction so we actually have like a
standard developer satisfaction survey
that is just like a customer
satisfaction survey and that goes out
once a year and we evaluate the results
from that to help build a better program
but beyond that I think again we have
this really strong developer evangelist
and he's out there you know every day
having meetings with some of our key
developers and you know we I think we
have a really good sun sand and our
finger on the pulse of what our
developers want because of those
frequent interactions and almost any
significant developer partner in our
ecosystem you know we're constantly
asking them what we can be doing better
you know that's such an important
function I don't see organizations
consider enough they sort of leave it as
an afterthought almost like who's gonna
wake up every day and think about how do
I make it easier for developers to
engage with us and never dress it so
it's great that you have that person in
place so Aaron how do you stay close to
developers to ensure an outside-in
perspective and ensure that your api
product design is a strong fit for their
needs yeah so I think I mentioned this I
mean we just have such a close
partnership on an ongoing basis with our
developers and I think not just
listening to you know what they're
asking for from us but sort of sharing
back to them the things that we're
thinking of and it's really a dialogue
and so you know oftentimes we bring
certain partners and very very early
into the process and you know we've had
launch partners come in even when a when
an API is in beta and I think we just
together you know we we learn so much
from each other and I think that kind of
helps us understand the developer needs
before we get too far down the pipeline
and that you know it is meeting their
needs and and then also meeting our
needs and do incentivize developers yes
we do
so we have a few ways that we do that I
think most notably we actually for a
couple of our api's we have a revenue
share so there's an actual you know
monetary compensation and I think
there's other ways of incentivizing you
know again the Walgreens brand is very
valuable so being able to talk about a
partnership with the Walgreens
and is something that is an incentive
and then finally those sort of indirect
incentives where we're enabling a
business metric that that partner has
through the services that they can get
through our API so that's awesome so
actually I think that's probably all the
time we have for questions so we will
make sure to answer our questions
you know separately online soon you see
responses there and we've got Googlers
as I said that are also answering
questions so I think that kind of wraps
us up I like to thank you once again
everyone for joining into into our
webinar today and thank you very much to
Aaron for joining us and presenting your
you know really amazing a Walgreens API
product story and reminder that we have
another webcast again next Tuesday and
we hope you can join us again then thank
you